rece Davis of College GameDay kind
enough to comment the program how are
you Reese rich I'm I'm doing great and I
look I feel for you I was I was watching
I was watching the game with with a
great Ohio State fan on Saturday and
horseshoe named Bob Schottenstein and
Bob has family members on on both sides
of both vigil hiyo stateside and they
sort the rivalries American fans yeah
yeah and there were there were several
Michigan fans in that suite with us that
I was visiting for a little while and
one of the one of the Michigan men came
up to me when I guess it was 21 6 or 7
what a 21-6 I guess and he said Reese I
can't take another loss I can't take it
and then does he you know then get back
in the game and then it get away it was
uh it's it's tough for you for you good
Michigan men so what and I didn't see it
coming man I'm not going to say I didn't
think a lot of state could win but there
is no way on earth I thought they could
do that to them no nobody saw it coming
Reese nobody saw it coming because of
the way that that both teams had come
into this game playing but I I knew what
was the fallacious concept of well look
at what happened against Maryland and
Michigan should be able to go up and
down the field at will and Ohio State
could be had at will I knew that that
wasn't gonna happen because it's just
you know the magnitude of the game so my
question to you is what what's the
difference why does this keep happening
Reese give me give me your two best
cents on that it has become a little bit
of a helmet game as in the nineties it
was on the other side when John Cooper
no hiyo stages couldn't beat them I
think as much as Harbaugh would hate
this I think they tightened up a little
bit I think they're trying so hard to
win the game break the streak all of
that that they don't play to the very
best of their ability and the other
things I think there was there was some
stubbornness dumped both sides of the
ball Michigan you know continuing to not
necessarily be as creative as some other
teams in college football offensively
and defensively when when it was a
parent Ohio State I have answers for the
press coverage and they could
pressure on Haskins they were unable to
adjust effectively so I think that's the
long and short of it and do you think
that you know Urban Meyer we all saw his
wife crying on the sideline and him just
slumping into her arms race that that
looked like a couple that knew that this
is the last game that they're playing in
the horseshoe that's the way it looked
to me I'm wondering if that's reading
too much of into a situation what do you
think I know I don't think it's reading
too much into it I don't know the risk
that that decision has been made fully
yet but I do know that there are a lot
of people close to the Ohio State
program who are not going to be at all
surprised if that turns out to be the
case so you know it's I you know as as
urban seemed like himself and watching
him and I didn't get a chance to spend
any time with mr. each I don't want to
make it appear that I did but just
talking with Jim majakowski who was
there and people around the program for
the first time really decision sort of
things like himself leading up to this
game but in the in the other games we've
all seen the anguished agonized look and
and appearing to be in pain and if if
that is your reality then I'm not sure
why anyone would want to continue if
those are the circumstances you're going
to be in you know from this point
forward so I think the short answer to
it is I wouldn't at all be surprised if
if he makes that decision but I haven't
heard anything that would indicate that
that is a foregone conclusion up to this
and before we get into the short-term
future of Ohio State and and its
national title hopes what are you
hearing about Michigan are you hearing
I'm not hearing any anybody in the fan
base or I guess booster base wanting Jim
Harbaugh's head on a plate but what what
do you think happens here for Michigan
on out
first of all you're exactly right about
that I know he's got every ounce of
support from ward manual the athletic
director and everything they're a lot of
times what happens when you have a
moment like that when it all comes
crashing down it sort of makes you give
yourself an honest self-evaluation Jim's
an excellent coach as you know and he's
done a really really good job
with building up and rebuilding the
program but you know they need to get
over the hump and I think that you know
I don't know if that means adapting a
little bit as we have seen Alabama do
offensively with your offense or you get
a few more explosive plays if it's you
know landing some more difference making
recruits on the edges whether it's a
change in philosophy for any of this
type of stuff this type of loss can be a
turning-point type of moment when you
start evaluating where you have fallen
short and clearly Michigan has fallen
short in this game particularly the
revenge tour exercise some of the demons
but the biggest demon is still sitting
there and they'll have a year to think
about it and Michigan can't be defined
solely by winning this game but a hefty
part of the definition must be winning
it because usually you have to win a
championship hmm so you know that he has
to he has to
I think evaluate whether he wants to do
a little more on offense whatever that
means or if he's got too many cooks in
the kitchen or not fences he too
involved is he not involved enough all
of those things that you can only answer
if you're behind the closed doors but I
do think it's it's a real opportunity
for Michigan to look inward and say okay
what do we have to do it's not good
enough to bludgeon our head against the
wall and think that we're going to be
tougher meaner enthusiasm unknown to
mankind if we will just out will you
that doesn't always work especially when
the other side has a pretty strong will
itself Reese Davis here on the Rich
Eisen show from College GameDay my kids
love watching it you're so good at it
too man and it's great just having a
you know been there for as long as I was
with you and seeing my kids go crazy
over a guy who used to research
SportsCenter and is now a personality
his own right chris FeliCa they love the
Bears Bank man it's great I just it's
just so fun to watch this thing Reese
you guys are great at it well well thank
you very much I appreciate that now I
mean you feel really good for the bear
because a year those of us who work
there do what type of savant he was and
how extensive his knowledge is not only
in college football but I mean
horse-racing golf you name it that guy
knows knows everything and to see him to
see him sort of evolved you know past
that and now is a part of the part of
the college football landscape and one
of the Paluxy figures on our show it's
been really cool for men and I'm happy
for him and he's a lot of fun you know
and he he's got some strong opinions and
he's not shy about sharing great it
really is just great so when it's when
it's said and done tomorrow night I'm
expecting here Georgia forth just so
they could set it up for the SEC
championship game and get Oklahoma fans
and Ohio State fans and a full froth
what do you think yeah I think it'll be
that and I think that's probably the way
it should be
at this point the bigger question comes
if Georgia Beach Alabama and as you
referenced FeliCa earlier and one of the
things that we already chatted about
online this morning
is he is up the opinion right now that
barring a blowout loss he would still
contend that Georgia should be seriously
considered him not ranked for even if
they lose to Alabama and you know I
think that would invite a debate but
certainly the the more obvious one is in
Georgia work or to win the game against
Alabama Saturday and then it becomes the
discussion among Ohio State Alabama and
Oklahoma and UCF potentially if they're
if they're able to win if it becomes
that you know where does it fall it's
the Big Ten Champion left out for a
third straight year now one of those
years Ohio State got into the big 10 to
non champion you know our people ready
to move through the era of football in
which you're often
can dominate your defense does just
enough which is where Oklahoma certainly
is where Ohio State has been for much of
the season so you know I think all of
those things are a really interesting
concept I'm still up the opinion that
even though I believe it's Georgia be
Calif Amma
on Saturday that Alabama is one of the
four best I believe that it is a I was
define it as a mosaic or a work of art
and I would think that either Oklahoma
or Ohio State my guess would be Oklahoma
would get the nod rather than Alabama
for that fourth spot I could be wrong
but I don't but I didn't envision it
last year I felt they I thought they
would go hi Oh state last year so I
could be wrong again but I don't think
Alabama can lose and get in without
either Ohio State or Oklahoma also
losing well I mean if Georgia beats
Alabama and the manner that Alabama beat
Georgia for the whole shooting match
less well so I still don't see them
telling Nick Saban you know go enjoy
what the Cotton Bowl or something you
know by the way if that were to happen
history shows is great and it's
consistent as Alabama has been yeah for
those of your viewers and listeners you
like to play games of chance
I would I would lay a lot against the
Crimson Tide if they lose Saturday and
and get left out of the playoffs because
that will be a tough building I can't
imagine that I can't imagine that at all
you know and so you know obviously
Oklahoma does have the Cuyler Murray
factor that I think a lot of people
because there is no question right Reese
and no or what a loaded way to ask this
question that that the committee will
take into account whether a games more
watchable with a certain player or or
star or organization or school involved
I mean there's no doubt about it that if
Carl Amari lice up Texas and Ohio State
has a go of it against Northwestern that
they'll choose Oklahoma
over an Ohio State team that lost to
Purdue right I mean don't you think I
you know what and I don't know if it
would be a watch ability factor because
I think there would be a case to be made
that athletic lis that Ohio State could
provide a bigger defensive challenge
ma'am in terms of watch of watch ability
but I don't think that would be wrong
necessarily risk they're their resumes
are virtually indistinguishable and much
as as I felt last year like I said
earlier and I did think that Ohio State
would get the nod last year that's just
what I thought they would do what I
thought they should do is was what they
did was put Alabama and Alabama was
better you can't lose by 31 - I expect
to get in it's a little different this
year because there's not the second loss
but that 29 point loss to Purdue is
significant and I I would favor I think
because everything else to me appears to
be relatively equal I think I would
favor Oklahoma over Ohio State at this
juncture because you know they lost by
three to Texas and they have a chance to
avenge their only loss they do that and
you have to split hairs I mean I would
favor Oklahoma over Ohio State because I
have a hard time envisioning Oklahoma
going into West Lafayette losing by 29
and you know I mean I know Oklahoma gave
up 42 Kansas and people can score on
might get it but you know they're not
gonna lose by 29 I mean you know in
terms of that Reese you know you kind of
channeled your inner first take on
Twitter over the weekend
tweet it out I'm sorry there are some
great individual performances in this oh
you West Virginia game but how much more
fun would it be to see them execute
versus competent defense is for me a lot
more fun yeah I mean I agree with you me
too and you know your tweet I'm reading
your tweet Reese I'm not agreeing with
you I'm just saying you know I know I
know I mean it's uh it's a situation
where teams are scoring a lot of points
in college football but the difference
in what I saw with Oklahoma in West
Virginia on Friday night while
entertaining in great theater there's no
one in the frame with guys when they're
running open and you don't see that
other places the
even some of the touchdown passes that
tore through against Auburn I mean what
does two of them the guy was dead on him
you know from Auburn he just dropped it
in their bets or entertaining to watch
to me watch them execute against a
defense that is legit I'm not saying
they can't do it I'm here to tell you
right now Oklahoma plays Alabama they
will score
Tyler Murray will make some he'll make
big time but there's no doubt about that
I just don't need to see him out in a
skeleton drill you know with with nobody
with nobody in the flame with any chance
of covering I Reece before I let you go
I noticed your guest picker was Bryce
Harper do you get any sense he's gonna
be a filly did he talk about that at all
I midst of all of his ohio state gear
all over the place we had we had a
little something planned we had a number
of hats and considered putting them out
and Bryce wasn't up for that now very
rare that a headgear segment could trump
Corsos but because that would have right
there Reese that might have done I'll
give you I'll give you another one they
were taking taking me to the airport a
few other people were riding with me and
the guy who was driving us got an urgent
call from our production coordinator
through who's just like a guy who can
make anything in the world happen and
boo goes please tell me you don't have
the keys to Bryce Harper's car in your
pocket and our guy we call him swaggy
Steve swag Steve reaches in his pockets
I seen you've always drive his eyes
close and say yes I do and food that
dropped him off as fast as you can to
get back here fast I'll try to keep him
on the field looking around until until
we can get back so so we've been we've
been kidding swag indeed that uh that
team's pulled their 450 million dollar
off the tape offer off the table because
Harper was late to a meeting with those
attempts yeah
mandated to ask you what uh what style
of car was the key in the pocket you got
it you know oh it was it was it was the
car that our runners were using to
transport it so it was just a rental
taco that's all know it's been his car
yes like that oh I see ah now I get it
because I mean yeah you know I mean I
don't know what a Lambo you know he
looks like that pocket or not but hey
race great stuff as always we'll chat
down the line hopefully in the next
couple weeks when things get even more
serious thanks to the call man
thank you bet cell Reese Davis the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience